allora buona sera a tutti sono chiara
burberi e stasera vi parlerò di stand
per tutti anche per le ragazze
iniziamo da dire che cos'è stemma chi lo
sa fantastico stand per chi non lo
sapesse vuol dire science technology
engineering and mar
quindi tutte le materie scientifiche a
partire dalla matematica e in
particolare parleremo della matematica
al linguaggio di base la grammatica di
base di tutte le materie scientifiche
perché ne parliamo perché sono avvolte
da sempre da grandi falsi miti che per
il nostro bene attuale e futuro è meglio
che iniziamo a combattere seriamente il
primo falso mito ce l'hanno raccontato
fin da quando siamo nati al primo giorno
di scuola
le materie stem sono solo per talenti
naturali le avremmo sentito tutti no è
certo la matematica è difficile è sì è
difficile e solo per quelli portati e
non tutti sopportati tuo fratello e
portato è questa è una classica frase
che ahimè le mamme spesso dicono
inopportunamente quindi tornate a casa e
smettete di dirlo ma la bella notizia è
che in realtà si dice di questo per
tutte le altre forme di arte non
soltanto per la matematica perché
incidentalmente vi do uno scoop la
matematica è una delle più grandi forme
di arte ne parliamo a un altro ted però
di questo troppo lungo reazioni un
grande talento naturale ha inventato la
lingua italiana
un genio assoluto ha speso la vita a
scrivere la divina commedia
ci sono anche le date che sembrano
maniacalmente matematiche esattamente
come tutta la sua grande opera un uomo
sì un uomo tre secondi per un grande
nome di donna che immediatamente vi
viene in mente simbolo della grande arte
della letteratura
vabbè capita tranquille siete non c'è
tranquilli normale ecco io che vanto
adorati studi classici a me viene in
mente quello ci ho pensato
cinque minuti e genio assoluto orecchio
assoluto talento naturale precoce 3 anni
5 anni concerti attenzione io ho sempre
pensato che fosse tutta una grande
messinscena del padre poi in effetti
aveva il talento assoluto dell'orecchio
assoluto o qui quindi il padre è stato
molto fortunato talento naturale o ore e
ore di esercizio e poi si c'era il
talento dell'orecchio assoluto vabbè che
la rende più facile difficile trovare un
nome di donna no ma anche l'arte della
pittura si dice no genio e sregolatezza
il talento e talento si vede magari
viene riconosciuto dopo mo di modigliani
viene riconosciuto dopo stato un po
sfortunato è però poi viene riconosciuto
però talento naturale un nome di donna
altrettanto noto bravissime infatti
volevo mettere lui sborgi was però
pensato dai diamo gliene una facile poi
lo sport e si nasce tennisti il padre di
agassi realtà sia un po pentito voleva
portarlo a imparare il golf perché
saresti durato di più gli ha detto un
fantastico 2.500 palline al giorno dorme
sul pavimento per il mal di schiena
punture di tutti i tipi odia il tennis
tant'è che non ha un campo da tennis
a casa ci mancherebbe altro un incubo
per le donne qui i nomi dico più facile
ci avete mai pensato perché perché ci
sono due campionati ragazze e quindi un
po di donne diventano prime naturalmente
fine abbiamo preso una veramente brava e
incidentalmente appunto moglie di va
bene quindi le stand sono solo per
talenti naturali
lo si dice di tutte le arti di tutti gli
sport di tutto ma io personalmente penso
che il talento non basta ci vuole
qualcosa di più
in effetti secondo voi cos'è che
accomuna davvero tutti questi personaggi
che abbiamo visto il talento la
dedizione e poi passione sudore passione
sudore volontà un meraviglioso mix di
skill e uil pochino di base ci vuole no
però poi la differenza la fa la forza di
volontà la determinazione
quindi il talento non basta
ma allora posso anche dire che il
talento non serve
no tutti noi scriviamo leggiamo
canticchiamo magari qualcuno suona pure
sicuramente quasi tutti nuotiamo se
siamo milanesi sicuramente sciamo
eccetera eccetera
mi dite cosa c'è che non va con le
tabelline e lo dico però ai papà perché
alle mamme
e chiaro che è tutto frutto di
allenamento infatti scommetto che le
mamme tra voi fortunate di bambini delle
elementari
a questo punto se hanno superato la
terza e quarta elementare sicuramente
sapete le tabelline perfettamente perché
teach tool si chiama siete state
costrette a trovare un modo perché i
vostri figli si memorizzasse rowe in
qualche modo le tabelline e l'avete
trovato anche voi incidentalmente detto
caspita non mi ero mai ricordata come
perché il 5 x 5 poi dopo e c'è una
diagonale
fai poi ecco quindi allenamento
il talento non basta il talento non
serve nella vita quotidiana perché la
matematica deve fare la differenza
rispetto a tutto il resto è solo una
questione di allenamento quindi la
matematica
dovremmo incominciare veramente a
considerarla come uno sport uno sport
qualunque dove più dall'eni più su di sé
più ti diverti quindi la matematica è
per tutti e poi c'è secondo grande mito
quello che ci fa male personalmente io
veramente detesto le materie stem sono
solo per uomini infatti se io dico
fisica voi dite
grazie sarebbe stato traumatico con o
senza linguaccia come dicono i miei
figli ma perché quella linguaccia è poi
te lo spiego va beh e invece no ci sono
anche loro
io questa l'ho scoperta grazie a google
l'anno scorso il giorno della nascita di
maria gaetana agnesi milanese grande
matematica del settecento contemporanea
di eulero assolutamente non ricordate in
italia che è maria gaetana agnesi però
google l'ha ricordata in un meraviglioso
doodle sull'homepage perché perché è
stata una pietra miliare della
matematica colei che sapeva commentare i
grandi matematici del tempo e poi ha
scelto terza di 21 fratelli un padre un
po così eccetera eccetera un'altra vita
però insomma questa è un'altra storia
e questa la riconoscete la da dei è
dedicata a lei una mano alzata però dai
fatti così
ada lovelace la prima programmatrice
figlia di lord byron grande matematica
il primo algoritmo scritto pensato per
una macchina calcolatrice quindi la
prima programmatrice continuiamo no
adesso gioco facile
perché fortunatamente ogni tanto qualche
donne emerge e siamo proprio fortunati
essere italiani non c'è niente da fare
e che dire della margherita tornate a
casa e fate leggere i vostri figli
lettera ai giovani di margherita hack
una meraviglia
scegli cosa che appassionano cosa ti
consigliano cioè giuro che don premio
chi mi dice cosa ha fatto questa qui dai
ha vinto un mega premio come si chiama
il mega premio la medaglia fields ma
mitica dobbiamo diventare amiche ottimo
maria mirza cani prima medaglia fields
al mondo donna perché ovviamente di
uomini ce ne sono abbandonate a medaglia
fields e il premio nobel per la
matematica il premio nobel per la
matematica non esiste anche questa è
un'altra storia per un altro test
meravigliosa e l'ha vinta 38 anni
afghana professoressa di matematica a
stanford che dice quello bravo in
matematica era mio fratello fantastico
un'intervista dal the guardian che
bisogna veramente leggere e memorizzare
perché di nuovo sfata un altro grande
mito non soltanto che le materie
scientifiche sono anche per le donne
ma per le donne che si fanno
accompagnare dalle persone giuste
lei racconta una storia meravigliosa di
collaborazione di aiuto di volontà
ovviamente sì di amicizia anche con
colleghi maestri persone che l'hanno
portata dove a vincere la prima medaglia
fields
e il terzo non perché il terzo per
importanza in realtà da qui nasce tutto
le materie stemmi in particolare la
matematica devono essere formali sono
serie devono essere serie perché perché
le raccontiamo così ai ragazzi perché ce
le hanno raccontate così quanti amano la
matematica qua dentro
sì siete pochi ne sono un v conto bandi
assicuro che a occhio siete pochi
simpatici ma pochi ti adoro pelle già
una mia amica
va bene ma questa veramente da qui nasce
tutto perché da qui nasce il fatto che è
solo per talenti naturali perché formali
pochi riescono a capirla no è un
formaggio è un formaggio è un linguaggio
criptico che è solo per pochi poi
incidentalmente sono pochi quindi sono
maschi perché i maschi si che si possano
dedicare tutto il tempo anima e corpo
alla matematica e quindi io cosa ho
pensato di fare questo è un tema vero
culturale questo non basta raccontare
storie qui va veramente cambiata la
cultura e se vuoi cambiare la cultura di
60 milioni di italiani si compresi i
neonati ai vecchi che sono tantissimi
soprattutto beh insomma come fai
come fai cosa fai innanzitutto da ex
consulente chiede un consiglio e da
donna
ho pensato richiederla un uomo altra
cosa che bisognerebbe imparare a fare e
ovviamente ho scelto il consulente per
eccellenza del principe niccolò
macchiavelli che mi ha detto sì il
figlio
ai mezzi più cosa non è etico
il fine giustifica i mezzi
però che adesso faccio io sono un
consulente poi ci si tuffa e ci ho
pensato e cosa ho deciso di fare di
fondare la più grande scuola italiana di
matematica perché se devi cambiare la
testa 60 milioni di persone che vengono
cresciute pensando che negati per la
matematica si nasce e non hanno capito
che si diventa perché te la raccontano
male e pensano che non serva e che tanto
non la capisco
devi educarli e quindi ho fondato una
scuola
red hook che una piattaforma online di
matematica la matematica da ministero e
quindi precisa come la vogliono loro
però po diversa una passeggiata tra
amiche con lo smartphone in mano è la
matematica che è sempre in tasca i libri
da otto chili in tasca
scegli l'argomento accumuli dobloni
perché se lavori bene sei premiato
questo concetto del premio no eh sì è
bravo ma non si applica potrebbe far di
più sei e mezzo vediamo gli sei così
capisce che deve studiare
eh no dice asterisco e poi d'estate la
passo come vogliono
e poi ti mettiamo in classifica ma non
per far vedere i 45 e i sei scarsi ma i
dobloni che hai accumulato e quindi i
nostri utenti sono in classifica e tra
l'altro combattono sacco i primi 100
sono attivissimi fanno impressione
perché si stanno controllando e quindi
stanno lavorando come pazzi una scuola
per tutti una scuola per tutti ma
soprattutto una scuola per ciascuno
perché non è vero che io imparo allo
stesso modo di qualunque altro io imparo
nel mio modo io troverò il mio modo
e così tutti soprattutto i ragazzi i
ragazzi devono imparare con il loro
linguaggio non il nostro no quello dei
professori che se pensiamo che è
perfetto
non è così che funziona e quindi ci
siamo inventati la geometria i triangoli
di peter pan le equazioni del sabato
sera
e visto che sono molto in ritardo
passere subito all'esercizio che vi fa
vedere le poligonali e cosi facciamo
l'insieme poi chiudiamo quale
costellazione contiene le poligonali
chiuse ma voi siete troppo brave
dovevate dirmi vergine io dicevo no non
è vergine ti dà feedback immediato bravo
e sagittario
vabbè la l'idea della scuola è una
scuola dove il professore e ti gasa ti
allena e proprio come un coach no prima
della partita di gaza e poi durante la
partita tifo da stadio
ve l'immaginate un professore così
durante un compito in classe di
matematica buon allenamento a tutti